it's so embarrassing but it's actually
something I actually need to speak about
so I think the most that I did was I
really liked this guy who was so sweet I
made a private Snapchat for him showing
the good sides of me because he wowed me
like we had a day he really wowed me
like it was so nice and then I made him
a private Snapchat and he didn't view it
or anything so I just ended up
self-sabotaging the whole thing I just
self-sabotaged the whole thing because I
was just like there's just no point of
me putting myself out there for making a
private Snapchat for you and were you
sending him like like pictures like that
oh yes I was giving something pictures
of me and my cat and everything because
he said he liked my cat so I don't know
okay